ما قد يبدو وكأنه واحة خضراء جميلة
هو في الواقع الجزء العلوي من بركان نشط
[موسيقى]
يقع في جاوة إندونيسيا هو
بركان الكولاجين في أعلى
بحيرة فوهة بركان شديدة الحموضة ، وتبلغ درجة حرارة المياه
90 درجة فهرنهايت ويظهر
باللون الأخضر المزرق ولا توجد أنواع تعيش فيه  أو حول
الماء حيث أن الظروف قاسية جدًا
على الطبيعة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ليلاً ،
يمكن رؤية ظاهرة نادرة على عكس أي
بركان آخر في العالم ،
ينبعث الكولاجين ما يبدو أنه
ألسنة زرقاء ساطعة هذا التوهج الأزرق ليس
بسبب الحمم البركانية ولكن بدلاً من ذلك من a  احتراق
غازات الكبريت بمجرد أن يبرد الغاز
بأشكال كبريتية صفراء زاهية يتم
استخراجها وبيعها ، ويستخدم عمال المناجم قضبان فولاذية
لكسر أجزاء من الكبريت
وحمل ما يصل إلى 200 رطل إلى أسفل
البركان ، وتكون الغازات المنبعثة سامة إذا تم
استنشاقها مما يجعل هذا شاقًا  العمل
خطير للغاية
بينما قد يكون هذا البركان الفريد موطنًا
لواحدة من أكثر الوظائف شاقة في العالم ،
كما أنه مشهد يستحق رؤيتك